the idea from these folks is only they
should be giving you information
and the biden administration is very
into this it is despicable and it is
authoritarian and is garbage
and you should be worried about it
whether you're on the right or on the
left or in the center you should be
worried about it regardless
because guess what this game goes both
ways we are now in the midst
of a great move from the federal
government led by the white house
aided and abetted and fostered by the
establishment media to shut down your
access to information you want to see
it is that simple what we are watching
right now is an overt i mean it's right
there in the public eye
it's an overt collusion between the
establishment media
which wishes to re-establish its
monopoly over informational
dissemination
between the media and the democratic
party which would like you to only see
the crap that the mainstream media is
often pushing and social media
whom both of the aforementioned parties
are now going to push
into shutting down your access to
information so to understand how this
works you have to sort of understand
briefly
the history of how informational
dissemination has happened in the united
states so if you go
all the way back the way people used to
get their information at the very
beginning of the republic
was a bunch of different partisan papers
and people would subscribe to them
pick them up they were largely local and
they were pretty openly partisan there
is a reason
why for example the arizona republic was
sort of a republican paper right there's
a reason
why the arkansas democrat gazette was
the arkansas democrat gazette right the
fact is that you would have all these
newspapers and they would have their
various partisan spins
and that's just the way that it was then
in the 1920s there was this move to sort
of regularize journalism
and the idea here is that journalism was
a process right you had to have double
sourcing for example you had to make
sure that every
factual claim that you made was
objectively verifiable
and that's not a bad thing but it led to
the rise of a professional so-called
journalist class
which would be fine if they were
actually just professionals following a
process the way that scientists
are supposed to follow the scientific
process instead what this led to was the
rise of a cadre
of self-described journalists who are
supposedly better at this than anybody
else and they
stopped doing journalism they went back
to being partisans but they just didn't
tell you
and so for years for decades in the
united states there as the
media began to nationalize as the means
of transportation became better and the
means of communication became better
there was a new mode of informational
distribution
and it was like tv there were only three
networks abc nbc cbs
that was it and everybody got their news
at night from these three networks
as far as major newspapers there were
only a few that were nationally
disseminated it's like the new york
times the wall street journal the
washington post that was pretty much it
and so everybody got their information
from these very narrow bandwidths
of information right these very narrow
means of distribution
then came the internet and it exploded
all this the internet basically
allowed anybody to put up news it was
almost a reversion
to the origins of the republic it wasn't
local it was national but
you could go to a wide variety of
websites you could check
a wide variety of perspectives and there
was this really
rich sort of interplay between how
people were writing
is in the very early days of the
internet then there was the rise of
social media and social media
as is so often the case was supposed to
facilitate all of this and now
has put it in danger social media was
supposed to give you
a one-stop shop for doing all this
instead of you having to
bookmark 10 pages if you're older than
about 18 years old you know that this is
how people used to do things right you'd
have a list of bookmarks
on the side of your web browser and then
every morning you would check like the
new york times
in the jerusalem post you checked the
washington post and you would check
national review you'd be able to check
all of these things right via the
book but via the bookmarks then facebook
because it aggregated so many eyeballs
because so many people were using
facebook for example
they've started providing a news feed
and the news feed was supposed to
basically make bookmarks obsolete right
when was last time you used a bookmark
right nobody uses bookmarks on the
internet anymore because instead they
have this
curated list of things that they read
and that curated list is curated
by social media it's curated by facebook
it's curated by for example twitter by
your by your twitter feed
okay so the idea here was that it was
supposed to be easier for you to access
all the information you wanted to see
the problem was that whereas before
because you were the person who's
clicking on all the bookmarks you were
in control of the stuff that you were
seeing
having handed control that over to
facebook or to twitter
for purposes of basically ease right you
didn't want to click 10 buttons instead
you click one and then you just watch
the scroll
now the democrats and the media have
seen
that as all information and
informational distribution is
re-narrowed
into these these narrow bandwidths
instead of everybody getting their news
from a wide variety of sources now you
get your news quote unquote from
facebook
and then you click through right once
they saw that everybody had to go
through facebook they realized
they could re-establish the monopoly all
they would have to do
is simply say to facebook that facebook
was guilty of deep and abiding sin
if they allowed you to see the
information you wanted to see
twitter needed to suppress information
that you
were not supposed to see it was very
important that if you liked information
too much that the mainstream media
and the democrats didn't like that these
social media platforms
instead of easing your ability to see
information restrict your ability to see
information
so the entire rationale for these social
medias
these social media networks being in the
news business in the first place got
reversed
instead of them making it easier for you
to access information democrats in the
media seeing that you were now using
them almost universally
they decided this is a great way of
ensuring
that you don't see information this is a
great way of purging these particular
outlets
of the information restricting your
ability to see them
shadow banning preventing advertising
they could reestablish their traditional
monopoly by using these giant companies
they're going to leverage these giant
companies into doing what they wanted
and so you have this bizarre spectacle
of the media who are supposed to be
the great defenders of a free press i've
never called for cnn to lose its license
i have never called for the new york
times's distribution on facebook to be
reduced
because i don't care it's not my job but
these other
outlets will do that cnn will do that
about fox news the new york times will
do that about the daily wire
npr will do that about the delaware as
we'll see the idea from these folks is
only they should be giving you
information and if information
is obtained from any place else then
facebook has done something deeply wrong
and they will be the judges of what is
good information and what is not good
information
and the biden administration is very
into this this is authoritarian nonsense
it is authoritarian i have a book coming
out next week called the authoritarian
moment it is all
about this this is i mean the timing
couldn't be better it is all about this
it is about the attempt by the media and
the democratic party
using social media to abort your ability
to see the information that you want to
see in authoritarian fashion
it is ugly and you should be worried
about it whether you're on the right or
on the left or in the center should be
worried about it regardless
because guess what this game goes both
ways if you're a republican in office
we're saying that facebook should
restrict information from the new york
times
the media would be going ape bleep but
because they are
because the media are complicit in this
now the media are the greatest
weapon against free speech happening in
the country right now
the democratic party are fully
participatory in this because
they must have utopia and they will do
it at the price of your ability to
access information
it is hideous to understand the origins
of the new anti-social media push
the attempt to use social media as a way
of
restricting informational flow you have
to understand there was a tremendous
reversal that happened with regard to
left-wing views of social media directly
after 2016. so when trump won in 2016
the social media before that was
considered this godsend you'll recall
that there are articles in 2012 about
the brilliant use of social media
by the obama administration and the and
the obama team in the 2012 election what
an amazing job they had done
in using social media to reach the
people they wanted to reach and facebook
was a tool for this you'll remember
facebook was a tool
in the arab spring facebook was a way
for oppressed and suppressed people all
over the world to get out their message
then
trump won and suddenly the democrats
deeply in need
of some sort of narrative to explain
away trump's win instead of just saying
hillary clinton was a horrific candidate
which is why she lost
instead of doing that the media and the
democrats latched on to a narrative the
narrative was
facebook twitter your social media
brethren
all of these giant companies they were
responsible and the re the way they were
responsible is they had not properly
policed themselves for things like
russian disinformation russian
disinformation
this stuff was super dangerous now here
is the thing
the russians did try to intervene in the
2016 election
their actual activity on facebook if you
read into the senate reports
does not even chart in terms of
important things that happened with
regard to social media in 2016.
like the actual amount of attention
their posts were getting was actually
low if you know the metrics but
that doesn't matter the narrative had
been set and the narrative was that
these
media these social media outlets were
being used as props
by cutouts essentially from foreign
countries
then something subtle happened all of
these informational outlets
members the media the democrats they
shifted the argument from its russian
disinformation
meaning actual agit prop put out by a
foreign government in order to pervert
an american election
which is actually dangerous and which
should be prevented on social media they
moved from that to
from disinformation to they just
switched one letter misinformation
misinformation was anything democrats
didn't like now
social media had to step in and prevent
misinformation not disinformation right
disinformation is an actual term
that is used in the intelligence
community to talk about a foreign
government
subsidizing agitprop misinformation can
mean anything
misinformation can mean the hunter biden
story a month before the election
misinformation
can mean that you don't think anthony
fauci did a good job during this
pandemic
misinformation can be nearly anything so
long as the media call it misinformation
and then call on the federal government
to pressure facebook
into preventing its dissemination you
can basically
leverage facebook into doing whatever
you want right the shift from
disinformation to misinformation is
deeply important
at the beginning the social media tech
bros they were kind of resistant to this
they said yeah we have to do a better
job with russian disinformation but the
reality is that we
are platforms right and as platforms it
is not our job
to go around trying to discern true from
false
in a variety of public sect we're
literally a platform in the same way
that like your phone line is a platform
right when you get on your phone line
and you tell your wife that you're
you'll remember everything at the
grocery store and then you don't
that does not make the phone line
responsible for you saying something
untrue to your wife
facebook is not responsible i mean
legally or morally they are not
responsible
for people saying things that are untrue
and certainly they're not responsible
for a subjective claim that some people
think is true and some people think is
false and and
at the beginning facebook kind of
acknowledged this right many of social
media's
heads would say yeah we're not
responsible for that freedom of speech
requires
that we allow opinions that we may not
like and allow dissemination of
information
that you may think is false but is
actually arguable and we need to have
conversations over
and then over time as the democrats
pressed you started to see social media
react to the to the press they started
to react to this this started last year
particularly during the pandemic when
social media started
cracking down on people who suggested
for example that the
chinese lab leak theory was correct they
started saying you can't disseminate
that that's false you can't put that out
there
if you say on some platforms that a man
is a man and a woman is a woman
now all of a sudden you could see social
media crack down on you
i know people there's a feminist name
megan murphy for example who was kicked
off twitter for the great sin
of saying that a man was a man and a
woman was a woman he started to see
the shift from disinformation to
misinformation actually activated inside
social media
and now it's coming to a head now it's
coming to a head because joe biden
the white house the media believe that
this is their shot to consolidate power
forever they believe that their shot at
consolidating power
requires a crackdown on informational
dissemination the lever that they will
use
is they will say that social media are
not just bad they're not just providing
you a space to put out things that are
false they are killing people right this
is always the democrat
and media excuse for cracking down on
your freedoms is that you're
quote-unquote killing people
right this is why the the far left has
decided that words are violence
that speech is violent we have to stop
it if we don't stop it
people will die and if people will die
then we must use
all the weapons at our disposal
to prevent that and that may include
suppression of some of your freedoms and
it will certainly include pressuring
these social media companies into
shutting down the flow of information
this is the exact argument that joe
biden is now making with regard to covid
it is despicable and it is authoritarian
and is garbage
again i'm going to pitch my book the
authoritarian moment shameless plug
right there because it is all about this
how the left is weaponizing america's
institutions if you want the country to
fall apart
if you want us not to be able to have
conversations this is precisely the way
to do it but this is not about having a
conversation
this is about shutting down a
conversation from people who are
very much afraid you might get your
information from a place
they do not approve they don't just want
to be quote unquote journalistic
gatekeepers who prevent
untruth they want to be gatekeepers of
content who prevent you from seeing
anything you don't like
period end of story this is their goal
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed